I absolutely love Star Trek The Next
Generation one of my all-time favorite
shows it might be my favorite show I
want to jump back I heard a story about
how you got involved on that show and
it's so crazy and I just can't imagine
that it would ever happen again in
today's world so how did you get
involved I want to make sure what I
heard is actually accurate yeah I mean I
was living in Los Angeles trying to be a
writer and basically I started dating a
girl who had a connection to Star Trek
The Next Generation and she found out it
was a Star Trek fan because I had
Captain Kirk posters of my apartment and
she said oh you know I still know people
over there I could get you a tour the
sets and they used to have a regular set
to her like once a week they would take
people on this Star Trek sets because so
many people wanted to do it and she has
made a call and said I made you know
they said sure you can get on the tour
and I'll be in about six weeks so I just
I did I was gonna shot and I sat down
and wrote an episode and I tucked it
under my arm and I brought it with me on
the set tour and I convinced the guy
that was giving the set to his name was
Richard Arnold to read the script and he
liked it and gave it to my first agent
and Richard was one of Gene
Roddenberry's assistants and so the
agent submitted it to the show formerly
it sat in the slush pile for about seven
months and then Michael piller the late
Michael piller came aboard at the
beginning of the third season looking
for material start going through the
slush pile found the script bought it
produced it asked me to write a second
one I did a second one and then after
that he brought me on staff and I was
there for ten years you know I was it
was a very lucky amazing break you know
that God you know you very I was very
young I was like 25 it's crazy that that
happened because it's so I mean Star
Trek The Next Generation had a very
unusual they had a different policy
where people could submit scripts or
that is that was the case right yeah
after well I'm kind of responsible for
that because after Michael found my
script Michael decided oh this is a
great resource we should you know open
the gates up to the fan community and
people that want to write for the show
so he negotiated a deal with the
Paramount lawyers where if you filled
out this
release form anybody could submit a
script to the show and so we started
getting like 3,000 scripts a year and we
had like Fulton at least five full time
script readers who did nothing but read
next-generation scripts and then wrote
up coverage on every script and then
every week the writers of which I was
one at that point would get this stack
of spec scripts with coverage and we
were we would have to read the coverage
and then people would be invited some
there there was maybe one or two scripts
that were bought purchased outright
after me I think Tin Man was a script
that was was purchased and then there
were a couple of stories that were
purchased but there were a lot of
writers that came in and pitched for the
first time because of that and some of
them sold stories Bryan Fuller I believe
God has got his start that way and Jane
Espenson I believe also it's it's
amazing
um you I believe worked on 27 scripts on
next generation what was it like back
then because nowadays you know every the
modern technology the way we're talking
to each other modern computers the way
people can work is so different than it
was back in the 80s and early 90s what
was it like writing for a show like that
when the technology was just so
different it was amazing I mean you have
to remember you know it sounds
antiquated now but at the time we were
all working on what was state-of-the-art
equipment or at least we thought it was
you know I I worked on a Mac at home but
they didn't have Macs at the at the
studio so we had to use these IBM pcs
and they were like black screens with
with amber lettering at at the beginning
and the big five and a half inch floppy
disks and then graduated to color
monitors and the three-and-a-half inch
disks still didn't have them networked
together there was no internet you had
to if you want something printed out you
had to take the disk down four flights
of stairs give it to the script
coordinator they would do the printouts
for you and take it back up changes were
done on the margins hand written in the
script and then you gave it to the
script coordinator to actually type in
the changes but it was a point of
transition you know there was still a
secretarial pool a typing pool at
Paramount which meant there were women
that were in that pool who had been
typing scripts for literally decades and
if you wrote your script in longhand you
could send it to the secretarial pool
and they would type it up in the
format and sent it back to you the same
day it was like you know I was literally
a survivor of like the era going back to
I Love Lucy when they would do stuff
like that
so it was really something and you know
the internet came in while I was at Star
Trek and working on Star Trek we were
always very interested in technology and
so there were first adopters among all
of us different people were buying new
computers and Macs and upgrades and you
know people start talking about the
internet and it was feeding our sort of
Technos eccentric kind of view of the
universe you know or view of the future
so we always were sort of trying to get
the latest and greatest stuff you know
AOL was a big deal you know although all
the stuff at the primeval era of the
internet happened while I was at Star
Trek the first message boards and you
know fan communication changed pretty
profoundly once what's the internet came
through it was a fascinating time one of
the things about Star Trek the show did
I think 20-something episodes a year
which is a massive beast of a production
for a sci-fi show what was it like in
terms of each season trying to figure
out the ultimate arc how much was it
changing on the fly you know I'm just
curious about the way you guys developed
the seasons back then well in next-gen
you have to remember it was very
episodic
this was before the era of television
embraced story arcs and character arcs
you know there was a mandate the studio
was very adamant that it did not want
continuity between the episodes because
we were first-run syndication show it
went out straight to this local
syndicated stations and those stations
wanted the ability to show them in
whatever order they wanted to they
didn't want to have to get locked into a
certain a pattern of showing and the
studio was frankly afraid that you know
viewers tuned in to episode 4 of a 5
episode arc and they went oh I missed
the first three last crew and I'm not
gonna watch any of this so it was a very
different mindset right so when we would
were developing the show you weren't
doing arts you you at the beginning of
the season we were doing 26 a year which
sounds crazy now but we were doing 26
episodes and you would just start
keeping you know putting up one-line
things of concepts for episode on a big
board
and you are mostly looking for a variety
of storytelling you know you were trying
not to do two mysteries in a row you
were trying not to do two Putin to
Picard stories in a row you were saying
okay we'll do this Picard then we're
gonna do a Beverly story then we'll do a
Worf story then we'll do another the
card story then you know you would
mixing it up in terms of the characters
and the style of storytelling that's too
many trying travel episodes a season
let's not let's not do that one here
let's do that one next year let's how
many we're gonna do one cue episode you
know okay we're gonna do one a Borg
episode you would it was really about
diversity of storytelling and the rhythm
but so that you weren't doing the same
kind of show right to row so with that
many episodes we never mapped out the
whole season ahead of time you barely
you were always trying desperately to
keep ahead of production and there would
always come a point in the filming of
each season where you were pretty much
hand to mouth where you were writing
them and they were shooting them and
you're writing and shooting and it's
just like you were just barely keeping
ahead of the camera at certain times and
then you'd have episodes that we're
disasters or got thrown out for whatever
reason it had to be completely rican
sexualized and there on the stage and
there was a tremendous pressure cooker
in the staff room and as a result you
never got that far ahead you know at the
beginning of the season you might map
out the first five or six episodes and
then you have to start writing them and
then time is clicking and so you get a
chance to start breaking then the next
couple says the next one and maybe some
freelance robot to pump out the night
energy got
but again you just know and then it's
just very you're just trying to
desperately begin a script out in time
to prep next week and shoot the
following week and it's just going like
this because they were all so short
short shooting schedules we shot an
episode in seven days you know seven
days is really tight so that means you
only had seven days of prep before you
had to start shooting so it was like
boom boom it was very it was a
relentless kind of schedule and because
it was my first gig was my first time
working in television I didn't know any
better and I just thought this was
normal and this was like okay I just
gotta get get with the program because
everyone else is doing it then that's
how I learned I just learned by like
okay this is this is normal TV and we
just have to
really work really hard as writers all
the time because Star Trek never really
worried about the ratings I mean the
Reagan's were always great and there was
no network because it was first
syndication
we never read the word
so we all got rolled into next season
once we finish shooting season four
writers would get two weeks break and
then we'd be back
five while doing post-production I was a
fortunately for watching the never
really start you there's a slight hiccup
with the the internet on your end but it
worked at the end there did you have a
favorite character to write for on
next-gen no I mean you you learned to
write for all of them and I enjoyed
writing for all and they all had
different graces and they had different
reasons to write for them it was fun to
write data because of the data's humor
it was fun to write the big sort of you
know Klingon stories for Worf and Picard
had the moral you know ethical dilemmas
there was always some something you
could grab onto as a writer so no I
genuinely favorites that I had it was
just fun to write for the whole cast I
think all good things the series finale
of next generation is a straight up
masterpiece inside it's incredibly
difficult to end anything you know to
give resolution to characters and make
people happy I [ __ ] sorry for the
language I love that episode can you
talk about if you were one of the people
responsible for that one can you sort of
talk about what it was like writing the
series finale and did it ever almost end
up being something else well you know
it's interesting we Brandon and Brandon
Braga and I co-wrote it and we were
writing Star Trek generations at that
point and we've been working on
generations for almost a year and there
was an ascendant among all of us on the
writing staff the Michael piller
was going to want to write the finale of
the show himself and ultimately Michael
was busy with Deep Space Nine and I
think he was even working on Voyager at
that point and decided that he was gonna
have Brandon and I write it and we were
thrilled and excited but it was also
like right in the middle of working on
generations so subtle I think it was
like this double load that we had to do
and we were doing to to our pieces about
the exact same characters on the exact
same ship and there were times when we
were working on a script like an
engineering problem with Geordi and Dana
talking about how to tech the tech for
the warp drive and we would get lost and
which story this was like which way is
this the movie or does the is a TV show
and the IR the great irony of it all is
that we spend
like for weeks working on all good
things and we spent a year working on
generations and all good things turned
out so much better it's just like one of
those one of those crazy lessons that
you learn as a writer but to answer your
question no it wasn't really some ever
it gonna be something else it was always
pretty much about you know the three
stages of a man's life which was
Michael's idea I think bran and I had
pitched there were various pitches on
what it could have been but it never
came close you know Michael pretty much
locked into this notion of visiting all
three periods of the captain's life of
getting the enterprise at the beginning
of what it was today and his life in the
distant future so that once week that
core kind of like then it never really
changed you know radically after that do
you remember who came up with the idea
of Picard joining the crew to play poker
um I don't I think that was like that
might have been even earlier I think
that the notion that we were gonna end
the show with the poker game was
something I think we talked about in the
writers room for quite a while so I
think that was always like yeah and
it'll somehow whatever it is it's gonna
end in the in the poker game jumping off
of next generation I want to go into ds9
just love also ds9 it was one of those
fully formed shows right at the
beginning and I thought its own mission
its own everything do you feel like ds9
has gained so much more respect now than
when it was on the air or am I just
mistaking this no I think that's
accurate that's that's certainly my
observation and when we were on the air
we definitely felt like we were the the
forgotten stepchild or the Star Trek
franchise you know the next gen was this
had become the psychotic thing and
Voyager was gonna be the big new show
and that we were like the middle child
and we were the weird child and we were
the one that you know the show that
didn't go anywhere and the space station
stayed in one place with and had these
long political and religious overtones
to it and with it wasn't real Star Trek
you know to a lot of people and the
studio kind of shrugged it as to like
yeah I know it's it's fine it's they
were sort of wanting it to be a bigger
deal like closer which next gen was but
those of us worked on the show we just
had faith in what we were doing and we
told ourselves at the time don't love us
one day one day
it's gonna be special and then it'll do
really you know go down well in memory
and it's nice to see that that's true I
think I think the show has aged well and
I think you know we were doing long
character stories and character arcs on
Deep Space Nine and it was kind of the
first time of us doing that and we had
to force our way into doing that and
really kind of overcome a lot of
opposition to it because again people
just didn't do that kind of storytelling
in the one-hour drama format unless you
were a soap opera in those days and now
all of one-hour drama kind of moves in
that direction so people that do
discover Deep Space 9 now start to pick
up Owen there's this along character
arcs and there's he's gone going plots
and stories and it feels a little bit
you know ahead of its time I think
that's one of the reasons why it stands
up so well is those long character arcs
um you joined I want to say in season
three or four I could be wrong about
that okay so what was it like with you
obviously you leave next generation and
you're working on the movie did you
immediately want to jump in to ds9 or
was it one of these things where it's
like they're offering you a job stable
employment I mean because it seems
daunting to jump from all of that star
trek into even more star trek oh well
you got to remember I was a Star Trek
fan so I was like a big fan this was
like you know a godsend to be on the
show at all so as next gen was right
winding down I did I wanted to remain in
the Star Trek universe and the question
was where where would I go when I go to
deep space 9 or would I go to Voyager
which was just coming together at that
point Michael piller brought me down to
his office to talk about and he it was
his idea that I should take a look at
deep space cuz he thought it would it
would play more to my strengths I liked
darker stories and more ambiguous
characters and he could tell you know
things I struggled against on next-gen
about making the characters more
ambiguous and less morally clear on some
areas and more continuing storylines and
he said I think you should take a look
at deep space and also IRA bear who I'd
worked with on the third season of
next-gen was now running the writers
room at deep space and I loved IRA and
really wanted to work with him again so
the combination of those factors became
like maybe I should give a deep space a
chance and I sat down and watched a lot
of the episodes
when I was working on next-gen I didn't
really watch a lot of deep space I had
seen the pilot and maybe I'd seen an
episode here and there but Star Trek is
so all the show was so all-consuming
when I got home and I was gonna relax
and watch something else I didn't want
to watch more starch back it was like
doing something else so I really hadn't
seen the first two seasons any great
detail but when I started watching it I
was really I was really interested in
the characters and in the setting and
the space station and the geopolitical
politics they were going on with beige
or in the Federation and yeah it really
it really appealed to me and so I I
decided to go to deep space one of the
things about deep space 9 it pushed more
boundaries the next generation did
believe it was Star Trek's first same
set same sex kiss it dealt with a lot of
stuff did you at the time was there less
resistance from the studio in terms of
putting this material out there did you
have resistance in terms of trying to do
things that had never been done before
yeah I mean we were pushing the envelope
and there were definitely you know you
had to sort of overcome you know fear
it's all about fear you know there were
fearful executives at Paramount that
weren't sure we should do that but you
know we fought the good fight on it we
want and we were always trying to push
the boundaries of what well Star Trek
was I think that was something that the
writers on staff saw is our core mission
let's push Star Trek let's see how far
Star Trek can go let's see what the
boundaries of it are and then let's push
them further so we were always looking
for ways to sort of try to do something
there did you experience the same kind
of in the writers room ds9 also had to
churn out a lot of content was it the
same experience where you were just
rushing through it or was it at that
point any easier it was easier in that
you know it was a more stable writing
stuff when I started next-gen and this
the writing staff in the first two years
of next-gen have been very chaotic
there's been a tremendous amount of
turnover writers had been fired or quit
and kept kept churning for it well into
the fourth season and then at the end of
the fourth season and into the fifth of
next gen it started to code they started
to be a more cohesive and had settled
down and then on deep space it was much
more stable some writers came and went
but it was a much more stable group and
we
all had worked together for quite some
time so it was easier in that sense but
we were still plotting this giant thing
so it always felt like we could never
plot out all 26 at the beginning of the
year you could get maybe 10 of them you
know and have an idea of where things
like the Dominion War was gonna go or
what war for his first season arc might
be so you had a sense of confidence and
experience that allowed you to do it but
still by the end of the season it was
still very hand to mouth and you were
you were sweating the production dates
and you were desperately trying to get
rewrites out the door and it was it was
difficult it was it was a treadmill at a
certain point well one of the things
that you mentioned about ds9 is that you
had these season-long arcs and so did
you ever have at the beginning of say
season five the end of season five in
mind or was it sort of like did you ever
have those long ranging arcs figure it
out or was it always like we'll see
where it goes it was pretty much we'll
see where it goes I think it's you know
in Deep Space 9 in the last two three
seasons yeah we might have said here's
where we want to be at the end of the
year and then just stake that out as
like a target that we were going to get
to but didn't really have the
fundamental are Kallang the way so we
would have sort of a long range idea of
what the season five and six
you know endings were and then obviously
what the finale was generally going to
be but it wasn't we just didn't have the
time to really map out that kind of
stuff in detail because so much would
change to is also if you spent the time
to map out a 26-episode arc and then
started writing it chances are the first
couple episodes would go through so much
change and so much tumult you know for
production reasons for story reasons for
notes for all kinds of stuff that there
would be a huge domino effect through
all 26 so it was almost like wasted
effort to to really do a great amount of
detailed work like that when we knew the
first episodes would by their nature go
through a lot of change did you take
home any props or souvenirs from either
next gen or ds9 yeah I have a bottle of
story and brandy from corks bar I've got
some props from from the bar from dr.
Bashir's office and I have if you
remember
in next generation there used to be the
big gold ships on the wall in the
conference in the observation room of
all the enterprises I have all the
enterprises really I did I saved them I
saved them literally from the dumpster
uh it's amazing to me I've heard stories
about what they threw out and it's
amazing to me that that it was thrown
out there are so many fans that would
have been like I'll take it please give
it to me
well that's what I mean I got this call
michael akuto who was working the art
department as well there were great
graphic artists and did all kinds of
stuff just called me up and said Ron
they're throwing out the the gold chips
if you want him come get him and I was
like I'll be right down and I pulled my
car in and took every single one of them
are they in your house do you have them
on display I have them in my office
I put how to mount it up on the wall in
my office in the same pattern that they
used to be in the Observation Lounge
please I know you don't use social media
but can you please tweet a photo just so
wrong I might have tweeted a photo of it
at some point I thought I did maybe I
maybe I didn't I'll find one you know if
you did I'm not on Twitter all the time
I'm sure people have missed it I would
be more than happy to look at it now um
I have to Athens my last Star Trek thing
but have you watched Discovery Piccard
have you watched the Star Trek shows
that have come on since your time or do
you sort of like I can't look at these
I've seen him you know I enjoyed Picard
very much I went to I was I was invited
to premiere that was a very lovely
gesture that they made and you know it
was great
it was really I was surprised how
emotionally satisfying it was to see
Patrick you know in that role again it
really made me like wow this is really
kind of cool watching him be John Luke
again the same with Brent and Jonathan
and it was like wow it was it meant a
lot to see them up doing those roles it
was very cool